>> Hello, and welcome to this review course,
which is a prep for my graduate course on
operating systems. When I teach graduate students on campus
at Georgia Tech, I often find that there's a
gap between the knowledge they have of operating
systems at the start of the course and what
they really should know in order to get the
full benefit of my graduate class. This is not
being judgmental. But it is just that, not
all undergraduate operating systems courses are the same.
And you may have taken a course on
undergraduate operating systems a long time back. Or
maybe you were not that enthusiastic about operating
systems at the time that you took the
course. This review course is not meant to
be a substitute for an undergraduate education in systems.
Rather, it cover the topics many students have expressed that they
wished they had it before starting to take my class. Helping
me with this review course is Charles Brubaker, a PhD graduate
from Georgia Tech, now turned into a course developer for Udacity.
>> Hi there. With this course, I'll try to give you concise
explanations that will quickly put you
into a better position. To fully understand
the vectors and complete the projects of the advanced
operating systems class. With these goals, let's get started.